good morning Hank it's Monday October
20th welcome to my inexplicably yellow
life Hank I'm going to level with you
I'm in Columbus Ohio I'm super tired
after a long day of touring I left my
camcorder in Boston so I've got to
record this vlog on the iSight camera
till I get a new camcorder and I'm
wearing a sticker I don't even know what
side my pill did boobage am wearing a
sticker that says my heart belongs to
edward which is not accurate but i do
have four important pieces of
information to deliver to you piece of
information number one Hank you are
awesome I know you're awesome because I
just spent the two most awesome days
with you of my life in New York and
Boston it was in fact so awesome that
while I was in Boston watching Julia
Nunes play my camcorder that I filmed
every single video I've made with since
January 2nd 2007 blew up due to a
nuclear chain reaction of Awesome okay
it didn't blow up I just left it at the
event space by the way nerdfighters if
anybody happened to pick up a camera
that looks like it was you know the one
I've been using for the last 22 months
mmm email me link in the sidebar
link in the sidebar god link in the
sidebar piece of information number 2
Hank I was just in Columbus Ohio later
this week I'm going to be in Atlanta
Georgia that show starts at 6:00 not
6:30 and honestly you should probably
come early if you can
then Miami then Orlando the Naperville
everyone should come to the event in
Naperville it's going to be big it's
going to be fun it's going to be jokes
it's going to be awesome I'm also doing
an event on Saturday at 4 p.m. at The
Bookseller in Lincoln Square in Chicago
that event is going to be much smaller
and much faster and to be totally honest
probably not quite as nerd tastic but if
you want to tick it I'll give them to
the first 45 people who email sparks
laughs at gmail.com thing number 3 Hank
because I spend so much of my time in
airports and on the road people often
ask me John do you have any travel tips
yes I do never underestimate the value
of Purell I mean Hank I have become an
absolute Purell addict I'm not even
content to rub it on my hands anymore I
got to get a gotta get it on my face all
OH
that's a burn but it's a good burn it's
a good burn also remember to travel with
your nerd fight
wallet and most importantly never check
luggage now I know what you're saying
Hank but I have to check luggage no you
don't Hank I'm not going to be home for
33 days and that is all my luggage for
the entire trip how do I do it simple by
wearing dirty clothes after like three
days you completely stop smelling
yourself thing number four nerdfighter
gift exchange in blog TV shows Hank
since you and also lots of other
nerdfighters can't be there for every
event on the tour I'm live-streaming
everyone on blogtv also Hank for the
rest of the tour when nerdfighters give
us gifts we will deliver those gifts to
nerdfighters at the next tour stop so
for instance some lucky lady in Atlanta
is soon going to be the proud owner of
this guy this is going to allow me to
keep the carry-on luggage carried on and
also bring joy to the hearts of lots of
nerdfighters all right Hank to summarize
lost my camcorder your awesome blog TV
live shows for the entire tour
nerdfighter gift exchange is made of
awesome thanks to all the nerdfighters
for making my heart burst with the love
and it's okay to be dirty Hank I'll see
you tomorrow and as always best wishes